hello everyone and welcome back to 1970
Palma de Majorca inter-zonal tournament
it's around 10 Bobby Fischer with the
black pieces faces the the Hungarian
Botvinnik alive sport ish as they called
him I did his exclusive exclusive
positional style now after five
consecutive wins Bobby Fischer
got two draws and then finally in round
nine he suffers his first loss at the
hands of the Danish Grandmaster BAMF
Larsson this is around 10 like we said
he faces a lot of sport issue aside from
being a strong Grandmaster which is
pretty much self-explanatory as he's
playing in the intra zonal tournament
actually qualified for the Interzone all
tournament 12 consecutive times so
that's really insane and he qualified
for the candidate candidates tournament
eight times so let's check out this game
Porter has the white pieces and let's
see how Fischer will will fare against
the Hungarian bot Finnick
we have d4 Knight to f6 c4 e6 Knight to
f3 the antonyms oh and c5 transposing
into the benoni
we have d5 pawn captures on d5 seek
after Sun d5 and g6 Knight to c3 Bishop
to g7 this is all pretty standard Bishop
to f4 we have d6 and Queen to a4 check
you can't like immediately take
advantage of the d6 pawn with something
like night to b5 there's really not a
good way to defend this pawn but Queen
to a5 check will force the knight to go
back to c3 as it's attacked on b5 and
after 94 it's actually black will get
the upper hand
so after d6 we have Queen to a4 check
Fischer blocks and Bishop d7 and here we
have Queen to b3 Queen to c7 and now e4
so still pretty much all standard stuff
we have castles by Fischer and now
Bishop to e2 Fischer goes a6 preparing
the b5 and here interestingly whenever
you face the Pannonian someone plays a
six most more often than not you will
play a four but here a four is not the
best move
portage goes for four d best move which
is e five as
Fisher did allow it Portrush place it D
captures only five Bishop captures only
five attacking the Queen you do have to
move the Queen Queen to see it displayed
and here portage castles you could think
okay maybe maybe I want to go a four
here prevent official from playing b5
but there's there's no reason to do it
just yet
so instead portage castles and now
Fischer was a Bishop to g4 if Fischer
did try to take this opportunity that
Porter did not play a four to push B 5
and then porch can simply counter it
with a four and it's actually portage
who is much more developed here now for
example after captures captures night to
be six already a threat so Bishop
captures rook captures and now after
something like a knight bt7 Bishop to f4
the Fisher would have two isolated pawns
on the Queen side after something like
rook after a one it would be very hard
to defend the D spawns
so after castles we have Bishop to g4 by
Fischer h3 we have captures captures and
done Knight B to d7 Fischer gave up the
bishop pair but he was soon win one of
the bishops Bishop to d6 attack in the
rock rocky 8 and now a four only now the
sportage go for this a4 resource Knight
to e5 and here you could play something
like Bishop to e2 to avoid this trade if
you don't if you play well there's
really no good place to move it you're
not gonna move it to the d1 meaning and
moving it to d4 is pretty pointless so
Fisher definitely wants to grab this
Bishop and even if you play something
like totally weird and then even c4
Knight to b3 would be a possibility but
okay Bishop captures an e5 rather giving
up the darks were Bishop rook captures
an e5 and now this was the critical
moment of the game at the time this game
was played but today not so much because
the engines don't really agree with
devaluation of you know of grandmasters
in those days here Portis played rook 8
d1 and this is kind of the critical
moment where they were they said that he
should have played rook after d1 he that
he should have kept this rook on the a
file to control keep controlling the
Queen side and
to develop this rook and then they said
that after something like Ruby a
preparing b5 / you prevent b5 by playing
a5 and that
now while this rook is very nice and b1
very active that this rook will be very
useful on the Queen side keep
controlling the Queen side but okay rook
a to d1 was played here by poor Tish we
have looked to be 8 and now d6
opening up those lines maybe may be
preparing 95 the bishop is now eyeing
the b7 pawn Fisher now goes b5 a capture
some b5 pawn capture some b5 and rook
FTE one Fischer exchanges
rook captures rook captures and now
comes in Bishop to f8 a lot of moves
were possible here as the b5 bonus
attack you could push before you could
push c4 a lot of interesting ideas but
Fischer plays the best idea Bishop to f8
we have Knight capture some b5 as the
ponies attacked twice and now of course
you cannot capture here with the idea ok
the knight is pinned no it's not I don't
I can't really capture and after we
capture the Queen Knight will capture
your queen after we capture here white
will have a bishop for a pawn with an
easily winning position so after Knight
to be 5 official first place Queen to d7
now with a double attack against the b5
night
you have to defend the night as now the
knight really is pinned so Bishop to e2
and now comes Bishop captures on d6 now
the night is still pinned knight cannot
capture here we have Bishop to c4 and
now fish removes back Bishop to f8 we
had rook to d1 attacking Fischer's Queen
Queen to e7 and now comes Queen to d3
and it was in this position that they
agreed to a draw so after two draws and
the one defeated two bent Larsen Fischer
faces yet another draw against the the
Hungarian botanical our sportive and
okay it's the material is completely
equal its allies workshop against the
dark square Bishop so perhaps there
could be something if the position was a
bit different but here they both agree
that it's completely drawn after black
play something like Ruby 7 adding
further defense to the f7 pawn there's
really
no breaking through here the Queen and
Bishop are protecting this pawn that's
on a dark square you can't really use
your light square bishop for anything
here all fishers pieces are on dark
squares there's really no way to break
through here so they agreed to a draw
here and okay a very nice game but even
with two three rows and and the lost
Fischer is still in the lead in this
tournament so always always well for
Bobby and like I said you don't have to
win the interns own to qualify for the
candidates I you just have to make it to
the top six spots so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it we're
gonna cover around 11:00
very shortly and it's interesting a
large part issues are still alive and
well
to my knowledge he's now 81 years old
and while he still plays you know
occasionally for fun he mostly enjoys
singing operas as a hobby and in 2004 he
was awarded the sportsman of the nation
award which is the Hungary's highest
national sports achievement award so you
know always nice when when a chess
player achieves such an honor so I would
like to thank our good Mathers dog guilt
it's a mark boot big Philip
very short and the Mitchell Weintraub
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon with around eleven of
the nineteen seventy pound American
inter-zonal tournament and perhaps with
another round of the bill chest festival
season